[Music]
some House Republicans tonight they are
demanding FBI director ray investigate
the abuses of power under Jim Comey
Biden and Obama by the way what did they
know when did they know it and what
happened in that meeting in early let's
see January in the Oval Office they were
all there that Susan Rice memorialized
on Trump's inauguration day Oh much
later
remember what we revealed last week the
FBI director found no derogatory
information on Flynn and they were ready
to close out the investigation struck
SEP in please keep this open and Jim's
Comey oblige despite no good faith or
factual basis to do so and as Andy
McCarthy rightfully points out a
powerful new column the FBI set up Flynn
because he was an obstacle in the larger
Trump Russia hoax that's how bad it got
and here to explain more we have former
Republican congressman Fox News
contributor trey Gowdy okay everything
we said and reported is true when I read
that letter last week what is our goal
here is our goal to get an admission is
our goal to basically force somebody to
lie and get them in a lie and the Logan
act is our goal to prosecute is our goal
to get them fired is that should that
ever be a question that any FBI agent s
because that's not the FBI I know I hope
it's not the FBI that exists now but
that that's something Chris ray is gonna
have to have to answer for how much is
the FBI change you're right Sean the FBI
is not in charge of hiring and firing
directors of National Intelligence the
FBI is not in charge
Manaus their job let's see what they can
get away with as Jim Comey said to that
giggling gaggle of liberals when he was
doing that Q&A that is not the FBI to
see what you can get away with try to
get somebody fired trying to catch
somebody in a lie you're supposed to
investigate crime not create crime but
Peter struck is the antithesis of
fidelity bravery integrity which is what
the FBI stands for so you and I
shouldn't be surprised the same guy who
launched the Russia investigations the
same guy that wanted to get Flynn and
ultimately wanted to
Tromp alright so I'm watching the AG and
I'm watching John Durham the prosecutor
they and my sources are confirming to me
they're the ones that insisted this be
released I have not seen any urgency
from director ray I would like him not
only to answer Jim Jordans questions but
furthermore I'd like to know what he's
gonna do and when he's gonna do it does
he have a commitment because I watched
him and said it and then in hearings
answering questions he shows no urgency
to clean up the premiere law enforcement
agency in the world he looks to me on
the outside like an institutionalist and
that concerns me yeah it shouldn't take
a letter from Jim Jordan to get these
questions answered you know Donald Trump
picked Chris Rea bill Barr is his boss
the United States Senate which is
controlled by Republicans confirmed
Chris Rae
I want to know is this still the FBI
does the FBI still try to set people up
for lives because you don't like the
person that they work for
what has changed that would be my
question for Chris look he went around
in 2016 but he's been there two years he
owes us an FBI that we can all have
confidence in and that is not the girl
that exists right now do it for the 99%
what the American people need to be able
to trust you know when Jodha jennifer
was right it but it kind of made me
flinch when he said dirty cops let me go
to another topic and that is okay you
have 50 states you have a federal
government I was skeptical of Governor
Kemp and Georgia's measures on tattoo
parlors but I kind of like some of the
creativity to open up salons and people
get manicures and stuff then we see the
draconian measures of whitmer for
example in Michigan as governor Huckabee
was saying everybody in Michigan should
be ticked off she did a horrible job and
by the way now she's she accused
Kavanagh believes Biden okay I guess
she's auditioning so my question is when
you can't plant seeds and you can't get
seeds and you can't cut your lawn and
these are ridiculous measures denying
people their rights I understand their
anger I didn't like the guys I would I
want people to be heard for the better
part of it by believe in the first and
second amendment but my question is what
do you do when these governors are
screwing up so badly
oh well we have a rich history of civil
disobedience and and and the people of
Michigan need to say you're asking us to
do these things tell us why what is the
rational connection between what you're
making us do and the outcome you hope to
achieve and if leaders can't convince us
of that then maybe we need new leaders
all right trey Gowdy thank you as always